scientists may have found a way to
predict how long you will live police
forces in the UK for dick crimes that
might happen before they take place
you're basically saying is a 60% chance
that Republicans win the Senate that's
right when it comes to delivering
packages an item could be sent out
before you even buy it on the Amazon
site
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody I'm Ira Flatow
thank you as you can tell from the
presentation this says this little
meeting is about predicting the future
you saw all the things that we can
predict now this is an age of prediction
people are trying to predict everything
that you do who you're gonna date who
you're gonna what they're gonna buy how
long you're gonna live we know something
about it from your genetic code
what kind of consumer you are what's the
weather gonna be like what's the future
gonna be like we're gonna talk about all
those ideas and especially given that
prediction and how do they collect all
this data that they know all of this do
you feel that your privacy is being
invaded every time you go on you know
tumblr or Hulu or in those kind of
places and people collect this stuff
about you so they can make predictions
about what you're gonna be doing where
you're gonna be shopping so we're gonna
talk about the future what kind of big
math is used do we need quantum
computers to help us collect all of this
data that the NSA probably has already
for you so yeah that's what we'll be
talking about let me let me have a seat
and introduce our panel of guests who
are really good and they're studying all
of this stuff let me introduce them to
you he's a professor of political
science and medical genetics at the
University of California San Diego and a
2010 fellow of the John Simon Guggenheim
Foundation his research has been cited
more than 10,000 times and is a Claim
book connect that has been published in
20 languages
James Fowler let's see
he's a professor at the MIT Sloan School
of Management Director of MIT laboratory
for financial engineering a principal
investigator at MIT s computer science
and artificial intelligence lab and is
in authority on hedge funds and
financial engineering and he proposed
applying evolution to financial markets
see how that's worked out Andrew W hello
welcome he is currently the professor of
quantum mechanical engineering at MIT
and director of the Keck Center for
extreme quantum information theory he's
the first person to develop a realizable
model for quantum computation his
research focus is on the role of
information in a complex system and the
quantum mechanics of living systems
known as quantum life quantum well I
have to get into that economics and
cosmology Seth Lloyd he is the Jacob
Gould Sherman Sherman professor of
applied mathematics at Cornell
University he's the author of nonlinear
dynamics and chaos sink and the calculus
of friendship his latest book is the joy
of X Stevens pro-gas welcome
how many of you would it be safe to
assume that everybody here posts tweets
they have a Facebook account or on
tumblr raise your hands if you're you're
into a lot of these things okay
well James Fowler believes that if you
drill into all of those post tweets and
I think they're called pins you can
predict a lot about us tell us tell us
let's start with the data how much data
is there out there to collect from what
everybody well it's crazy that we were
trying to collect data on Twitter
ourselves we're only getting 1% of it a
day and we're filling up the maximum
hard drive that we have now about once a
month and so so this is gonna be
multiple hard drives multiple computers
over the course of just a year and
that's just Twitter Twitter's just a
hundred and forty characters at a time
you go to something like Facebook where
you have all those rich information
about pictures and videos and social
interactions it gets gets even larger
mm-hmm and so why why a limited Twitter
enough to tell you what you need to know
yeah well what do you learn from all
that well any data is is good data I
mean you know I'd like to talk about
this in terms of the power of friends
really friends can be used in four
different ways to predict the future
first of all your friends are data and
that what they do you are also more
likely to do we've seen this through a
number of different studies if they're
obese you're more likely to be obese if
they smoke you're more likely to smoke
if they're liberal you're more likely to
be liberal on all these different
connections we can predict something
about you by knowing something about
your friends we also know that friends
influence one another until there's some
of the reason why you and your friends
are similar is because you can change
your friends minds in a way that they're
stranger can't we also know that friends
are multiplier effects so that if I can
just count up the total number of
friends you have that's one way for me
to figure out what's happening with you
you're connected to hundreds of people
online and so if you make one change as
possible that's going to change dozens
in some cases hundreds of people that
you don't even know and then the last
thing is that friends can be used to
predict epidemics and the way that we
can do this is by looking for the people
who are most connected in these online
social networks in order to find out
what they're doing because they usually
tend to do these things first when
something is spreading to a network does
it have to be my direct friend or could
it skip my friend
friends and you know what's good what
they're doing well that's that's the
really fascinating thing is that
sometimes we're finding that it's easier
for us to predict things about you by
looking at your friends data and your
friends friends data than it is your own
data and the reason why is because even
though their data is lower quality it's
much higher quantity
you know scale to hundreds of friends
let me just going up to tens of
thousands of friends of friends you have
all that information that's gonna guide
you to figure out what kind of person
you are and you can you can predict
actually that you mentioned the spread
of epidemics has that actually proven
successful yeah so we have a couple of
implementations one in a real world
social network where we showed that
certain people if you select them from a
real world face-to-face social network
people who are your friends because
they're more popular they tend to get
the flu before you do up to two weeks in
advance
these people are central throughout the
network and we've done this on Twitter
now to predict what's gonna go viral
which hashtags are gonna go viral and in
in that case you can get sometimes up to
two three months advance warning on the
things of and get the most retweets the
most mentions on Facebook on Twitter
Kenna can I influence what my friends do
by if I say I'm gonna take it done I'm
going on a diet I want to lose weight
does that radiate out into my friends
community let's say on Twitter if I
tweet I'm you know I'm going on some
sort of diet today yes and so we've seen
correlation between you and your friends
and your friends friends and even your
friends friends friends and these
networks and there's an experimental
studies that show that when you make a
change that actually affects the people
that you're directly connected to so at
least some of the reason why you and
your friends friends friends are the
same is because of this influence is
propagating to the network hmm can you
influence who they're gonna vote for by
saying I'm gonna vote yes now we have
not studied that explicitly but we did
do a 60 million person experiment on
Facebook in the 2010 election how many
of you might have logged in an election
day in 2010 on Facebook raise your hand
so you were members of this experiment
and we showed some that's right thank
you very much
we showed something they did you know
you we can talk about ethics later if
you want
so so we showed some people a message
and didn't show other people the message
and was random so there was nothing
about you that was correlated with
whether or not got a message and the
people who saw the message voted more in
real life because we match it to
publicly available voter registration
records and their friends voted more but
what if what if I don't have any
Facebook friends you know I'm one of
those few people who didn't do anything
am I left out of this am i okay
is the data bad because you're only
taking people who tweet or have Facebook
so first of all more than 60% of
Americans who are adults are active on
Facebook so this has really penetrated
people at all ages and if anything usage
is somewhat higher in older people now
because teenagers have figured out that
that all their moms and dads are there
so they don't use it as much when they
go to college they they tend to get back
on to it but but there's a lot of people
there and we know that Facebook users
are a little bit different in some ways
they tend to be a little bit more
extroverted maybe a little more
concerned about privacy but by and large
they tend to look a lot like the
population as a whole
so what else beside what things would
you like to predict that we're going to
see everybody being crowd-sourced what
things would you like to predict that
you can't predict at this point well I
would love to use the social data to
predict how long we're going to live and
you can do that we're working on it how
[Laughter]
with how much accuracy that's the open
question but it looks like so far in our
early trials it looks like we're going
to be able to get at least as much
accuracy from the friend data as we are
from your own data because if you tell
people that they're gonna start worrying
right thank you well hopefully you're
shaking your head right so we have
information about cause of death in some
cases and so we can we can not only sort
of partition out how long you're going
to live but what you're likely to die
off and so you can imagine that you know
there's all kinds of behaviors are
correlated networks because we choose
friends who are like us and because we
influence them and so there's
information in those friends about
things that could lead to your death
like drinking behavior like obesity you
know the
these causes of death that are very
prevalent all right if you have lots of
enemies you might die sooner because
you're not friending them unfriendly I
don't fret my frenemies let's let's talk
separately let's talk about what's
behind all of this you hear a lot of
these days about Big Data and machine
learning what are they what is their
role in this revolution in prediction
what's so as James was saying we are
collecting vast quantities of data a
data set that that I can imagine might
even be available sometime in the next
few decades you imagine the the
information about the entire genome of
every human being on the planet so there
you know there was soon view there'll be
roughly when this happens around 10
billion people so on the order of 10
billion bits of information for our
genomes so this is 20 billion bits it's
actually more information than you could
store on the hard drives of all the
computers in the planet but we'll get to
that there is that's right so now this
would be an amazingly useful and
potentially very productive data set to
you know identify possible genetic
diseases of people to look at that be
able to you know trace trace your
ancestry and trace relationships between
people on the other hand it would also
be a dataset where I'm not sure I would
want my insurance company to know what
was in my piece of him so you can you
have these gigantic amounts of data that
are there they're already out there and
that we're acquiring and then
potentially of a great deal of use not
merely to try to sell people stuff you
know but the big data is by definition
these very large amounts of data and
it's far too much information for
individual people just to look at and
try to understand so people like James
are making techniques to parse through
this data and via computers and learn
what's there so that's machine learning
when when machines learn what is in this
data
gonna be even bigger because
increasingly we are learning that we are
influenced not just by our own genes but
the genes of the organisms that live
within us that the microbiome and that's
going to be you know another order of
magnitude that we're going to have to
deal with my DNA first and then my
e-coli 23 billion and me well depends
what you mean by belongs
I feel I possess the contents of my gut
but maybe we feel different in terms of
math Steve Strogatz how revolutionary is
do we need new tools we got everything
we need or to analyze all this data and
make these predictions or we trying to
figure out how much more we need I feel
like from the math side we're way behind
on this that when I hear you know
reference to machine learning the
machines may detect patterns and
correlations they do machine learning is
this impressive technique in computer
science but very often after it predicts
correctly certain correlations it's very
hard for the human beings looking at
that to see what exactly was found and
I'm a little bit reminded of the days of
epicycles you know a long time ago when
Ptolemy was the great astronomer trying
to figure out how the planets move and
he and earlier astronomers had this
theory about the planets moving in
perfect circles that were orbiting on
perfect circles she had these circles on
top of circles and it gave actually very
good account of planetary motions except
today we don't think that it's the right
theory and so I sort of wonder if we
might be through machine learning
building epicycle models of big data
that is work what I'm trying to say is
seeing patterns is not the same as
understanding you don't know what those
patterns mean learning
machine learned is the machine learned
the pattern it's looking for the pattern
it's also a machine teaching I mean it's
telling us what it's found but it's you
know roughly speaking it's it's you feed
it a bunch of things to look for and it
then Jordan shows you which of those
have the most predictive power or which
combinations of them have the most
predictive power and sometimes you could
take a sort of agnostic approach where
you just throw in like all kinds of
statistical things that you don't even
know what they would mean just to ask it
should I wake that heavily or not and
and it often returns peculiar things
that are hard to interpret sometimes
though they're very transparent and you
suddenly realize like it can actually
show you something it can sift the gold
out of the yes like give me an example
something like there well I think there
was a case recently of a study of
Facebook done by my colleague John
Kleinberg and his former student Lars
Backstrom who now works at face but
maybe James knows it study better about
so let's see they're looking at couples
and that is people who are married and
then you also look at or me I don't even
know if you have to be married is it
just with spouses or could it be your
significant other but the idea is so
each of us that is me and my significant
other on Facebook we each have our
friends and then the question is
something about how do those friends tie
to each other are they like em are they
tied directly to each other or do they
only know each other through us through
this couple and then the question is
given the structure of this pair
friendship Network what does that say
about the stability of our relationship
are we likely to get divorced or not
based on the topology of our network
that might sound like a crazy question
to ask and it turns out that there's
actually really serious predictive power
in that you want to finish the sentence
yes this is a very interesting the first
door thing they're trying to do is is
give me your facebook data and what I'm
gonna try to do is I'm going to try to
guess who your boyfriend or your
girlfriend is without any
self-declaration structures that works
people just in any one person you're
just your own network the people you're
directly connected to and so to from
that one of the things that they found
is that
your significant other tends to be
connected to all the different
communities of people that you're
connected to so you're likely to have
introduced them to your childhood
friends your high school friends your
college friends your work friends much
more so than anyone else in your network
and if you haven't done that then the
second stage was you're in trouble once
you hear it but but the the relevant
metrics that had to be used to look for
this we're not things that we in network
theory had thought about before that is
Kleinberg and backs from had to invent a
new concept that they called dispersion
that was not a standard network theory
tool but it but the machine learning was
sort of revealing you should have
thought of this and once you did then
you're not Ptolemy than you're Kepler
that is now you actually have insight
into what the data are telling you the
way that Kepler did with Tycho Brahe's
data in astronomy so I feel like what
we're looking for is with these machine
teachers or machine learning than
teaching us that we can go from being
Ptolemy to Kepler to having real insight
into the big data and not just sort of
like listening to the Oracle telling us
these predictions that turn out right
but we don't know why so that means all
of our privacy is gone right everybody
shake their privacy privacy I think so
so I'm I actually have this talk that
they give about called back to the
village one of the things that people
pointed out and early as the Facebook
was oh it's so embarrassing now because
I post my pictures on Facebook and oh I
got a little a little drunk last Friday
night and before nobody knew about that
because I live in the city and there's a
lot of anonymity but if you think about
early village life life in the ancestral
environment if you made a fool out of
yourself one evening everybody knows
about it
so our desire for privacy say you know
about it on the other side of the world
right but we probably don't care about
those people we care about our village
and the idea of privacy is itself I
think an anomaly in human history it's a
product of living in cities which we've
only been doing for about a hundred
years we're just having the point where
majority of people live in cities and so
I'm I kind of think what's happening is
social media is taking us back to a time
where we
lived in these communities where there
was a lot of awareness about all the
things that everyone that were connected
to our doing but we're hearing stories
now that with facial recognition coming
into it to full bloom now that people's
wherever they go that they're gonna be
recognizes there's capability you're
shaking your head about this is
capability to somebody to know wherever
you are 24 hours a day and you don't
think that's different than loss of
privacy than it used to be I think that
every time that we have had a
technological innovation where privacy
was eroded there was concern expressed
about it people were very worried about
about this so that the telephone
like when we we got the telephone one of
the biggest complaints was men were
saying that now there were all these
dandies in the world they could apply
their masculine Wiles and steal their
wives away from them because any
stranger in the world could reach in to
the home and you see this exact same
kind of concern with sexting and with
cyberbullying your bullying is not new
we have always had bullies this is
[Laughter]
what's the documentation that that was
that that once happened I mean it's
amazing that so we have a citation in
our book connected I someone was writing
about it at the time when telephones
were the big new thing yeah and there's
also some of this with a telegraph even
the Victorian Internet yeah there's a
book called a Victorian Internet that
talks about that concerns about privacy
violations then with with the Telegraph
[Laughter]
people laughed at Bell because they
thought it was just a toy no Dahlia that
there's no money to be made in people
talking - uh-huh and they were a lot of
people could have invented the phone at
that time there were other people huh
Elijah Craig people like dad but went
but it was all about and this is a good
segue to dr. Lowe it was all about big
business and what would what would big
business do with the phone and you know
the same reason the telegraph was opera
was invented was to send stock market
quotes around how do you you know big
business actually turns out that Bell
was wrong and then 150 years ago when
the telephone was invented he bet that
people wanted to talk to each other they
said no people want to send document
no one's gonna use the phone took 150
years or so to show that texting
document is the way to go because no
one's into the phone anymore
the talk on it but what wait a doctor a
little dude does this big data have to
do with with business well I mean there
are a number of different implications
so first of all I agree that you know
it's been a tremendous you know boon to
both business you know and individuals
all around to be able to have access to
this data but I think along with big
data goes Big Brother in the sense that
now businesses can actually monitor all
sorts of activity that have real
economic consequences for them and
potentially negative consequences for us
so Seth you mentioned that you don't
necessarily want your insurance company
to know about what you're doing but
actually there are some situations where
you might so for example nowadays
certain insurance companies are offering
discounts if you're willing to allow
them to monitor your driving activity
this is called the insurance telematics
where if you're willing to let them
install a GPS device in your car and
pretty soon it's gonna be an iPhone app
where they can monitor not only how you
drive but how fast you drive how often
you drive where you drive to if they are
monitoring all of those things they can
give discounts to those individuals who
are good drivers the consequence is that
they can actually deny insurance to
those who aren't good drivers and so I
think that's something that we have to
think about there are some really
serious consequences of this big data
that are fascinating but they also can
have some very unintended consequences
that we need to be concerned about is
that the thing that flow gives out in
the commercial web about that is that
really the device she's giving out the
place in your car and monitor her there
are examples I don't know she's the one
who's doing that but you know I've seen
something in the commercial but but
there are there are insurance companies
out there that do offer discounts for
those who are willing to do that and you
can imagine that across all different
kinds of insurance health insurance for
example so we talk about you know the
diet and you know losing weight and so
on
well you can imagine a situation where a
health insurer will give you a discount
if they are willing if you're willing to
let them monitor your diet and that can
have tremendously important public
health implications if we get a sense of
you know what eating habits are where
the problems are lying what's creating
diabetes but at the same time it also
creates some potential you know
invasions to your privacy
if for example
but you had a little bit too much to
your drink and you know you are dealing
with certain kinds of addiction is that
the kind of thing that you really want
to be broadcasting on Facebook I think
we have to keep that in mind
ken can you tell by observing big data
and people's habits and things like that
how the stock markets gonna go well it
in fact there's a study that we've been
working on that's looking at Twitter
data and we're not trying to forecast
the stock market for profit purposes but
we're looking at where but we are but we
are looking at things like volatility
and it turns out that when you get a
certain increase in tweets about a
particular stock take a ticker symbol
for example when you get a certain
number of tweets and it goes up over
time you can actually show that the
stock market volatility increases for
that particular stock so imagine if you
can monitor all of this traffic on a
real-time basis you can actually get a
sense of how the market is moving when
we're about to get into a potential
crash and ultimately be able to do
something about that well let's say I
wanna I start to create a conversation
on Twitter about a certain stock because
I know you're watching it right well
deal with that well the stock market is
one of these really interesting things
where it matters not just what you think
but also what I think but more
importantly what I think you think and
what you think I think you think and it
goes on and on and this is where ruby
science behind it well actually there's
quite a lot of science behind it you
know one good example I would say it's
poets call it Finance but but actually
the bit to make that distinction
explicit you know one of the one of the
benefactors of this festival is the
Simon's foundation the Simon's
foundation was started by a
mathematician by the name of James James
Simon's a first-rate mathematician
author of chern-simons theory which is
at the heart of some modern-day string
theory ideas but about 20 years ago
Simon's decided to start a hedge fund
and this is probably the most successful
hedge fund in the history of all
investments and what he does nobody
really knows what he does because it's a
hedge fund but what people think he does
is use big data and he use big data
before it was called big data and he
constructs patterns
that are able to be used as predictive
measures for our trading do these
patterns come from anything in nature
that we would be looking at for another
science reason take the math or the
statistics of that and apply it to the
stock market or hedge funds well there's
a lot of that in fact there's a rumor
that part of what Renaissance
technologies that's the name of the
company that Simon started a rumor that
part of what they do is a speech
recognition and the rumor got started
because at one point Renaissance hired
the entire IBM speech recognition team
from the Thomas J Watson research labs
so I think that there's a lot of science
maybe what they do yes that's right what
speech recognition people one of them
was George swag who thought of quarks
you know around independently of Murray
gell-mann and so it's just a generally a
genius person aside from working on
speech recognition is just a very
high-powered mind but some of the
younger people that also were hired were
people that I you know we're my
classmates in undergraduate math courses
also tremendous intellects and just a
couple of interesting little facts first
they all want to still be professors I
asked them you know like how much money
do you make they don't really want to
talk about that what do you invest in
besides Renaissance just the same thing
you would the S&P 500 so so there are
certain surprising things but but to me
the most surprising was that what
they're really looking for they don't
want people trained in finance or
economics they think that they are
corrupted by lots of you know their
polluted by the wrong training so what
kind of scientists do they want to hire
or mathematician I thought this was
amazing there's a very specific niche
that they like the best you want to
guess what it is is it close trickier
who would deal with noisy data and be a
physicist JPL JPL very good it's
something like the Jet Propulsion lab
they like astrophysicists because the
the data that comes from stars you know
is going through the atmosphere it's
hitting turbulence and and so they're
not the physicists that are studying
super clean
in the lab that's the wrong thing for
someone doing finance you want to you
want the brain of a physicist but the
dirt of someone who deals with with
noisy data and can cope with it and
apparently astrophysicists are the sweet
spot
woody what is an astrophysicist get
versus this guy who's gonna work on what
don't ask me I mean Andy knows the
numbers I don't know yeah an
astrophysics professor makes about a
hundred to two hundred thousand dollars
a year at a good elite university so
yeah I think 20 million for Walter
that's yeah that's chump change is this
still a drain it still is there still a
brain drain physics going I think
they're I believe that for quite a long
time they've been more people with PhDs
in physics working on Wall Street than
there have been on the faculties of the
physics departments in the country it's
not as if Wall Street is seducing all of
these physicists from a higher calling
it's the fact that we're producing so
many physicists that don't have jobs
because we actually that even though
they're making many tens of millions of
dollars a year these guys still want to
be professors that is there something I
mean we're at the World Science Festival
science is extremely appealing I've no
disrespect to finance but in their heart
all these guys the topologists and the
physicists and astrophysicists they're
all asking me what's it like to be a
math professor they still really in
their heart of hearts want to do that
but they're it's hard for them to give
up in finance you know you have two
people who have their feet on the ground
but they're as you're saying their head
in the stars they really have to have
very good mathematical skills but they
have to a very good empirical knowledge
of what's going on and a way to put
these models together so the natural
person you want is an unemployed string
theorist for that because these are
people increasingly are being recruited
as data scientists because the day that
we deal with is way Messier then
probably even an astrophysicist has dead
what so we we get lots of training and
statistics after training in
econometrics and lots of training and
applied problems which you don't see a
lot of good calm skating a lot of
economists their their peer theorists
and so it's been interesting to me that
it's a lot of the non a cos have been
pulled into Silicon Valley to work for a
lot of these organizations but just to
underscore the obvious they you have to
be able to compute you have to be able
to code as we say nowadays if you can't
program computers comfortably you're not
in the game you read something
interesting about whether all this data
and all this collection of data of even
though we're all connected together when
we have all these friends and Facebook
friends people are still lonely very
very long talk about the studies that
are involved in this we actually studied
the spread of loneliness which is sort
of interesting because loneliness is how
we feel about connection and there's
actually only a slight correlation
between feeling lonely and actually
having few friends when we ask people to
name their friends but one of the
interesting things in that study is that
that feeling can spread that sense of
being alone even if you have lots of
friends you might feel alone in a crowd
and and not only what did we find in
that study that when you feel more
lonely that you're likely to have fewer
friends in the future but also when you
have your friends your maliki to feel
alone in the future so there's this
back-and-forth thing that happens where
the edges of the network can actually
sort of get frayed like pulling a string
on a sweater which gives us idea of how
important it is to reach out to people
who are disconnected to try to keep this
from infecting the whole network so one
person is loneliness can make other
people feel lonely and that's gonna make
right I should emphasize though that one
of this and this this place is one of
Steve's points this is based on an
observational study and so we use
statistical models to try to figure out
how much of this correlation is actually
the result of a causal process but we
don't have the good mathematical models
of that yet there's a big debate now in
statistics about how you tease these
things apart if you and I are the same
how much of this is the fact that I
chose you as a friend and how much of
this is the fact that I influenced you
if it's one thing versus the other you
have completely different policy
prescriptions for what we should be
doing if it's not infectious if you just
choose only friends then there's not
gonna be any spillover effect from
treating one person it's not gonna
spread to other people how do you study
it then I mean if you don't have the we
do the best we can and there's those
different ways that you can can get more
leverage so one of the things that we
use is asymmetry and friendships so if I
asked you to name your top ten friends
right and then added three okay so there
you go so over two three ask them to
name their friends right
sometimes they won't name you back
that's why I have only three so we can
use that asymmetry because when you name
someone you're thinking of them they
seem like a friend to you you pay
attention to them but they aren't
necessarily paying attention to you and
so we expect that a change in you
predicts a change in sort of change and
then predicts a change in you but not
vice versa
and so that's one thing that we've done
to try to make it more likely that what
we're seeing in this non-experimental
data is something that's a causal
process but the math of it is actually
quite complicated sometimes and there
are enough that you said sixty percent
of people are on Facebook it's more than
six percent that's enough people even if
we leave out the people who are not who
are not tabulated because they're not on
Facebook that's enough to make a good 95
percent prediction of how people are
doing or what these data show well so we
are always obsessed in the social
sciences with representativeness right
so if I were to do a study on the
members of this audience right now
they're probably key ways in which they
are different from the general
population you guys are way more
interested in science probably the
average person in America but on
Facebook when you compare lots of these
different things they look very much the
same there's a little bit fewer more
women maybe a fewer more liberals but
these are tiny tiny effects it's like
well 1% difference or something like
that well getting back to this question
of lonely so if everybody's passing
loneliness around and loneliness is this
communal thing then for me too or for
you or psychologists into somebody to
treat loneliness in some individual you
have to treat the whole Ground yeah
that's one of the implications if this
is a causal effect not just for
loneliness but for obesity smoking and
drinking happiness depression all the
things that we've looked at the
implication is that that these are
social phenomena
it's not one patient and one disease
it's you know it's a group that you
should be reaching and one of the things
we found in our drinking study was that
although men were more likely to drink
heavily women were more influential on
other people when they stopped drinking
and so if you want men to quit drinking
what our study suggested is that you
ought to actually treat the women
because you'd reach more men getting the
women to change and so it's the friends
who might actually want you want to be
the target of you when you want to
target the friends in order to reach
more people in the network and this is
idea of friends as multipliers the fact
that the women reach more people you
might get more bang for okay inspector
your ethics question that you didn't
want to touch if I know from my study
that this person is a drinker and I want
to help that person to treat that
drinker don't I have to go to their
friends and tell them that that person
is drinking not therefore you're shaking
your head yes yes and a no I mean don't
I have to reveal some sort of confidence
about that it depends on the
intervention maybe instead of like
raising the drinking behavior or trying
to dampen drinking behavior you raise
some other behavior that's positive
that's the substitute for that behavior
and you never have to mention it at all
but this is but that is an ethical
question do you want to ask is do you
reveal this or there was an incident
with target using big data to try to
predict who was likely to be pregnant
because they wanted to send out fire to
them oh we're good for baby clothes and
there was a dad who didn't know that his
daughter was pregnant and it yielded a
very difficult situation because they
inferred that target knew this and then
they found out and so you can imagine
that even though you have these
mechanisms in place that don't ever say
drinking people can kind of figure it
out
so the ethical questions definitely are
there so if you just shaking your head
like well I thought that targets main
big data experiment was to give away
millions of credit card numbers of the
Romanian mafia andrew is there anything
else about the stock market I mean can
can we predict or can we create I know
we've seen these flash trades and things
like that can you create something
erroneous by not
good data if the data you feed it it's
the old garbage in garbage out from the
old computer day
well definitely I think the stock market
is you know a very complicated beast
much more so than any kind of physical
system because you're dealing with the
human behavior and so I think that by
using data in the right way we can say a
lot of interesting and useful things
about the stock market but using data in
the wrong way we can actually create
panics crashes and other kinds of
instability and there's a lot of people
who savings are at stake so I think that
we have to be very careful about this I
don't know if it's gonna get us anywhere
but I'll just let it out there which is
that I feel like the word prediction is
being used in a couple different ways
and it might be helpful to distinguish
one being you know like if your friend
is chubby I can predict your chubby
that's a correlation there's also the
prediction in the old-school sense of
there's going to be a solar eclipse
tomorrow right that is to tell something
ahead of time that's not just a
correlation but do you see what I mean
it's a difference it's thinking about a
time series some events unfolding over
time in physics and in traditional say
physical sciences astronomy chemistry
you know if I say I can predict the
product of this reaction that's I think
of prediction as having to do with
unfolding in time and that's an
intrinsically very very difficult
problem that like when I see the title
of this session go figure predicting the
world with math I think good luck you
know there's it's very hard to do we we
can only do that in a few subjects we
can do it very well in astronomy if we
only study two objects that is if it's
the the earth going around the Sun yes
we Newton solved the two-body problem in
the 1600s it predicts that planets move
in ellipses they more or less do but you
know even Newton said that when he tried
to include the moon they referred to he
called it the problem of the moon
nowadays we call it the three-body
problem the Sun the earth and the moon
he said his problem never ached as when
he tried to solve the problem of the
moon and he couldn't solve it and no one
could solve the three-body problem and
in the late 1800s plonker a explained
why that the three-body problem
chaos in it that is slight uncertainties
in the states of the planets that is
where they are or how fast they're
moving quickly get amplified to a point
where we we can't make meaningful
predictions over the long term I mean we
can in the short term we know where the
moon will be you know tomorrow or
whatever and so of course you can do
rocket science the moon will be there
when you get there but but but five by
five five million years from now we
won't know where the moon is that is
it's been shown that the whole solar
system is chaotic you might not think so
you think the clockwork universe what's
more orderly than the solar system well
the solar system is actually a chaotic
system but with a timescale of five
million years meaning if we want to
predict out a few million years we're
okay but way past that we really don't
know where where the individual planets
are going to be with any precision so I
guess I sort of feel like when we talk
about these prediction problems we're
pretty good at the correlation problems
but they can me feel I mean maybe
they're the more important important
point
I mean you cares about the prediction of
time absolutely and and I think that the
distinction that you're talking about
house really to do with the degree of
understanding of yeah yeah
so to take your point about predicting a
solar eclipse right now we can predict a
solar eclipse to the millisecond of when
it's going to occur where it's going to
occur how it's going to occur but let's
go back a thousand years right move back
a thousand years the solar eclipse was a
religious event that you know held
tremendous you know political important
and you know there was very very great
efforts you know expended at trying to
predict them at with very little success
they had correlations but not
predictions right and so I look at the
world as different levels of complexity
allow for different degrees of
prediction so Mathematics Physics they
enjoy precision that most of the fields
don't in fact I think there's a
hierarchy of certainty that starts with
mathematics and then physics and then
chemistry biology and when you get all
the way down to economics you're dealing
with situations where we can't say
anything about the future but we in fact
that we're promised predicted
nevermind addiction yeah you got that
down so but I think it's the nature of
the beast and what it is that we need to
have better tools and we need to work
harder at these problems we need smarter
people involved and help them well we
should also not exaggerate what we can
do in physics I mean maybe Seth should
weigh in about you know there's
fundamental limitations through quantum
physics about even predicting physical
systems so in in quantum mechanics the
world is intrinsically probabilistic I
mean Einstein hated this he famously
said God doesn't play dice but you know
he was wrong he should we just have to
kind of suck it up or the world is
intrinsically probabilistic and and in
fact this gets these little quantum if
we actually look at all these chancy
events that you were talking about from
chaos what does chaos do why is it it
are things are ridiculous because the
things that are like the motion of the
planets amplifies tiny tiny little
fluctuations in in this motion until
they become unpredictable so actually
what the motion of the planets is doing
even though planets are gigantic huge
things they're amplifying what are the
end little tiny quantum mechanical
fluctuations and so bringing them up
into the macroscopic world so that after
five million years the fact that you
can't predict where your anus is going
to be oh sorry that actually in is in at
bottom a quantum mechanical uncertainty
in Uranus buttocks so there's actually I
just do I'm not going to disagree with
you Andrew about about I guess I'm going
to disagree with your hierarchy that
puts economics at the bottom so so
there's a in addition to this kind of
unpredictability that comes from
intrinsic chance eNOS there's a kind of
unpredictability that comes from the
fact that even if as everything is
deterministic there are certain things
we know we can't predict there's a
there's a famous example
this from Alan Turing's halting problem
which says if you set a computer going
on in program in a particular way
there's no way to tell what it's going
to do you know you can't help if it's
going to give you an answer or when is
going to give you an answer and this nun
comes not because it's in deterministic
or probabilistic it comes because these
computers have this kind of self
reference capacity and in in the case of
human beings we have this what you were
saying you know it's not just you know
you thinking about what I'm going to do
and I'm thinking about you're gonna do
but it's you thinking about what I'm
thinking about you're going to do this
kind of whenever you have this kind of
self reference self referential loops
you end up with a kind of paradoxical
situation that you can prove that you
can't know what's going to happen huge
gap between where physics is and where
the Social Sciences are for example the
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle tells
us that there's certain things that we
simply can't know and predict but that
doesn't stop you from building a bridge
that doesn't collapse and it doesn't
stop you from getting to the moon you
know it where where were those theories
in economics that could have prevented
us from having 11% unemployment couldn't
do that well but we have ways that we
have a whole advertising industry is
based on predicting what you're gonna
buy right we know enough about you we
would put commercials out we know how
you gonna behave
so that's prediction certainly in
commercials so that's actually something
that we started working on we actually
got a large commercial bank to partner
with us and give us their data for
consumer credit card accounts and by
looking at a 1% sample of their consumer
credit card data which is about a
terabyte a month what we were able to
show is that you could actually see the
credit crisis coming about 12 to 18
months before it actually hit now that's
only because Genting retrospect no no
actually you kind of said you know you
could have seen it a 16 to 18 18 months
ahead of time using early data that was
a holdout sample and so had we had these
techniques back in 2006 and 2007 we
could have actually started doing
something about it earlier on but at
that time nobody was looking at all of
the data in this way
doing that now they're starting to so
we're collaborating with the office of
the controller of the currency at the US
Treasury that's responsible for
regulating banks and we're using some of
these machine learning tools on 19 of
the largest banks data to try to see
whether or not we can identify these
problems a little bit more because I
thought I remember reading lots of
articles in the paper by people saying
that there were problems but then the
articles didn't get much traction that
is I don't I mean wouldn't you agree it
wasn't that we didn't see it coming it
wasn't exactly in fact we didn't we want
to go to a meeting together about risk
management with it and actually that was
a that was you know before it happened
yeah I sort of remember going at some of
the data that we had looked at was
indirect data from hedge funds that that
indicated that the risk was building on
yeah absolutely the problem is that
unless you get incontrovertible feedback
that a crisis is developing and by
incontrovertible I mean from you know a
well-respected third-party unbiased
agency that displays this it's very hard
to get action so for example you know
there are people that you know when a
big storm is coming their joints start
hurting you know they get a little bit
cranky and so if they started telling
you Steve you know you really ought to
move out of that you know you know a
waterfront apartment because a storm is
coming you might not take it as
seriously as if you're heard they're
from the National Weather Service we
don't have a National Weather Service
for a financial crisis and if we did I
think we'd be able to do a lot better
dealing with these kinds of things but
let me just put global warming into that
pot because we have a lot of data about
global warming and ninety seven percent
of the global warming scientists believe
it's happening and it's already going on
if there's a whole bunch of people who
still don't believe in it climate change
is complicated and it's complicated by a
number of factors one of course is the
science which is not transparent and
even though a number of the scientists
agree I think that there are some people
you're right that are simply
non-believers they just no matter what
they say they will not believe no matter
what you say to them they won't believe
it but I think there's a much more
complicated question which is let's
suppose it is true let's suppose that
the climate is changing what do we do
about it you see it turns out that it's
very costly for us to engage in various
different kinds of actions to deal with
climate change
and therefore it becomes an economic
question costs versus benefits so here's
the question the question is how do you
discount the future costs and benefits
it turns out that if you discount it at
a rate of 1.3 percent then we got to do
something right now it's really
important if you discount it at one
point one percent it turns out it
doesn't matter let the future take care
of it and so that trade-off between
current prosperity and you know future
generations it's a very complicated
question to deal with so I think we
actually need better analytics before we
can actually make a statement about what
we ought to do about it
I mean the fact that Florida is gonna be
underwater is not enough
well that doesn't move the bar at all
the fact that we have to move all these
people away from coastlines isn't so
effective so let me go so let me on yet
[Laughter]
all these people are gonna be displaced
all these industries are gonna be out of
business all these homes all these
flooding that doesn't move the bar well
suppose that in order to move the bar it
turns out that we actually have to
increase the poverty line by an extra 5%
because we'll have less money to spend
for social programs so now you're
trading off the people in Florida and
California and Massachusetts with people
in Montana and in Idaho and Wyoming well
if they don't have any rain our Texas
doesn't get any water that's gonna be
part of that no one it seems to me no
one is putting those numbers in about
not doing so right the truth about not
doing something that that forget the
carbon tax and all lies something
through the the truth of how all of this
is gonna be so so I wonder % what we
need to do is to ask better questions
collect better data to be able to ask
the right questions but frankly when it
comes right down to it you're thinking
about a carbon tax and other kinds of
behavioral adjustments I think that in
the end it's gonna be very hard for us
to deal with that it's a bit like
telling your teenagers you know to
abstain from from sex you know
abstention isn't a way to deal with the
problem but it's not very realistic so
what's the point of making all these
predictions well I think we've predicted
this is gonna happen if no one is gonna
do anything about it so look at night
everybody drive home safely you know let
me let me give you an example of what I
think what why we why we do this I think
that if we don't
anything I predict there'll be a number
of problems a number of scientists will
predict there a number of problems there
for the purpose of prediction is to get
all of you to start thinking about this
for example instead of worrying about
climate change carbon taxes and discount
rates why not start thinking about
geoengineering coming up with the next
generation technology two years ago
there was an announcement in nature that
they discovered a bacteria that can
digest methane gas which is worse than
the greenhouse gases what if we could
somehow genetically engineered bacteria
to remove some of the greenhouse gases
from the atmosphere that's one of the
reasons why I think we're here today
it's because having more scientists
involved and asking the right questions
developing better technologies is
ultimately the reason that we do this
and why prediction can actually be
important do you think scientists do you
think scientists should step up and be
more vocal about these things themselves
if they know this we're on stage here
and none of us are naturally photogenic
so I'll speak for myself
we must I've gotta say that no should
have having a whole bunch of 747s out
there dumping millions of pounds of
bacteria into the atmosphere I find a
little bit alarming when I take more
than a few 747 let's let's question
about so let's talk about freedom in
free will if you can predict all these
things are we beyond the capacity to
change any of these predictions about
how people behave I mean for example was
a really good example not only the way
Steve user but also in terms of the the
percentage of accuracy right so so we
can get that down to a single point in
time when we talk about predictions in
social science well you're usually
conceptualizing things stochastically
because we don't have enough information
about all the different things that will
affect a single human decision let alone
a whole set of people's human decisions
to say with deterministic accuracy what
exactly is going to happen we're never
going to be in a situation where we can
say exactly that you're gonna do X on Y
day the same way as we are with with a
with an eclipse and so the analogy here
is to physical systems like the weather
where where we we actually know a lot
about what's gonna happen over the next
five days in terms of the weather and
that's incredibly useful for us as a
society to learn that I would like to be
able to do that for political systems
and for economic systems to get at least
some short-term monitoring so that we
can prepare for these storms that are
coming towards us okay I'm sorry
which is that you know when you predict
tornadoes about to hit the fact that the
tornado knows your prediction doesn't
change its path whereas for economic
systems that's a real problem the fact
is that our predictions can actually
affect the way people behave and you
know this morning I mentioned at this
session that you know Richard phiman the
great physicist summed it up very nicely
he said imagine how much harder physics
would be if electrons had feelings and
in fact you know the because we all have
feelings the the marketing firms can
predict our behavior but as they engage
in certain kinds of marketing campaigns
we actually change our behavior in
response that's the complexity the
social sciences are the hard science yes
and why we start with physic
and then the chemistry and then the
social sciences I mean difficult science
the distinction is hard versus soft not
hard versus easy if you have the word
science in your disciplines names it's
not it's not like it's not a suggestion
that you are a scientist and suggesting
that you're worried you're not a science
library sorry my question did you want
it yeah so about you were asking about
about freewill yes and and indeed this
is you know we're in fact when talking
about global warming we're talking about
our our collective freewill as a society
can we exert it to change things that we
don't want to have happen and I'm a
little more concerned than than Andrew
is about about Florida being under water
I have to say though and can we then can
we predict what the results of our
actions will be both as individuals and
as a society so there's some I I would
claim that the answer is in general no
we can't predict that and this has to go
with to these these questions about that
I was mentioning before about Touring's
halting problem it says and this is
something everybody it sounds like
something that's very esoteric but
something everybody has experienced
because it means what the halting
problem basically means there's no way
to debug a computer program in general
there can be no universal debugger
because the very first thing you'd want
this debugger to do is say I type in
something or I click on this you know
will something happen at all and you
can't answer that question there's no
general way of answering that question
so when your computer crashes or when
things go wrong this is intrinsically
built into the way the computers work
it's also intrinsically built into the
way that societies and human beings work
so you know the central experience of
free will is
that you know I can't predict what I'm
going to do even on your very simple
things like it's four o'clock in the
afternoon
should I have caffeinated coffee or
decaffeinated coffee well you know
caffeine would be more exciting but
decaf is safer I'm not gonna know what
I'm gonna decide until I actually make
this true if he's right about what his
friends on Facebook are doing I didn't
say I didn't say that his wife might not
be able to predict what he can do her as
friends friends are all having decaf at
4:00 he's gonna have the cabin probably
that's the point we're just stick you
into a brain scanner the the
neuroscientists would know before you do
what you're going to choose that's
actually that's irrelevant to my sense
of having free will so so yeah some
neuroscientist could stick some
electrodes into my brain where you could
look at my facebook page or my wife
could actually because she knows me
would be able to know what I'm gonna do
but that's different from me knowing
what I'm going to do and I can't know
what I'm going to do you can take the
same math that Turin used to prove the
halting problem apply it to you you
yourself and say can or to me and say
can I know what I'm gonna do when I'm
making a decision the answer is no I
can't know what I'll get what decision
I'm gonna make some very substantial
fraction of the time and you can't take
that exactly that same mathematics and
apply to human societies or to economic
systems and ask is society capable of
predicting what is going to do and the
answer is no it can't not all the time
because of this endless kind of
second-guessing essentially that we all
do with each other right here I am
saying that we're close to the Minority
Report here instead of having those
women in the bathtub uh whatever that
was down there you have Facebook and the
other you and the other kinds of
predictive values of Twitter and the
other social networks and they can
predict when he's gonna murder something
I mean that literally when he's gonna
have doesn't have a Facebook page or
Twitter accounts predicting to Las Vegas
sense Las Vegas can make a lot of money
because they know that you're going to
do something 51% of the time and this is
the way can you know these companies are
gonna use this consumer the double zero
on the roulette wheel yeah exactly
right so you don't wanna play roulette
it's the worst game in Las Vegas and
they know that right so
so so it's not like we know exactly what
you can do tomorrow but we know we can
narrow the space enough that is very
useful if we're trying to change your
behavior ever trying to get you to buy
something if we're trying to change
society's behavior say in a good way or
in a way to make profits do we do we
know can you predict how good would you
be at predicting when society is going
to change its mind about something when
is it going to you know we saw up there
about the slides of predicting who's
could be nominated or elected president
maybe that's a changing mind or
something but what about its attitude
about global warming or evolution or
something when it's gonna make a
paradigm shift yeah there's some good
research on attitudes towards gay
marriage and how we've seen a real phase
transition in in those attitudes
changing and you have people like Robert
chilled aldini who have studied social
norms which it really gets into this I'm
gonna do what everyone else does because
I expect them to do it and I expect that
they expect I'll do it and when you try
to change people's behavior one at a
time it doesn't work because you have to
change these mutual expectations people
like Jerry Mackey who was really helped
with ending female genital cutting in
Africa the way they do is they bring
everybody out into the village square
and they all announce simultaneously
we're not going to do this because if
you just do it one house at a time
people don't see the other people doing
the announcement and it's that mutual
sort of declaration that has to happen
so when you see a change in something
like our attitudes towards gay marriage
one of the reasons why it takes so long
do the change even though people in
there's some evidence that many people
were ready to change their mind for a
long time before we all actually change
was that they didn't think other people
had changed yet and so as a result of
this phase transition is delayed
in in finance that was actually part of
the financial crisis you know it used to
be that 10 or 20 years ago if you were
to default on your home mortgage that
would be considered you know an absolute
disaster be shameful you'd have to look
at your banker in the eye and explain
why you couldn't pay but something
happened over the last 20 years where
after a while people began to realize
that paying a mortgage on a house that's
worth half of what it used to be doesn't
make any more sense and so a couple of
economists Apollo Sapienza and Luigi
Zingales did a survey of individuals
over a period of time to see what their
attitudes were towards defaulting in
your home mortgage and they found out
something really shocking which is that
over time over the recent past it became
clear that at some point the attitude
towards defaulting on a mortgage changed
so that it's not so much a shameful
thing but rather a smart economic
decisions the so called strategic
defaults began to become more common and
you can actually show that in
neighborhoods where somebody defaulted
it's a lot more likely that you're going
to default because you've heard about it
it's not nearly as big a deal the people
that you know are good people and they
default and so therefore it's okay for
you to default so that's an example
where if you could actually get that
kind of data and you can see that type
of social norm changing over time you
could actually predict when society was
gonna change in some pretty important
ways and there's another nice recent
story about the failure of big data
because you didn't take into account
that the ecology would change so you can
use searches on google for things like
COFF flu medicine to predict actually
how many people have the flu at any one
one time and Google create this thing
called Google Flu Trends that was very
very good at tracking the CDC reports
for how many people in the United States
had the flu it worked really great for
the first couple of years and then it
started working less and less well and
one of the reasons why as it was
reported in a paper by David Lazar and
and Gary King recently was because they
didn't uptake the model they didn't go
back to the CDC data to see whether or
not there were different words that were
predicting this and these online to
colleges are changing so fast the way we
use the Internet
it's changing so fast what but social
network here on
is probably different now than it was
six months ago for some people all those
things are changing so rapidly that
we're going to have to constantly
reconnect to real-world ground truth
data in order to be able to make the
right predictions is there possibility
and say danger that that people know
that they're being probed for all the
state and all this information and they
don't like it and they start saying you
know I'm gonna start lying about all my
stuff and see what that gets you of
predicting what I'm going to do is there
a danger that could happen when you're
lying so in in our voting study for
example we match 61 million people to
voter registration records we know
whether or not you got off the couch and
you went to the polls and we found that
our message not only made people more
likely to vote it made people more
likely to lie about voting so now I have
a model of not just the behavior but of
misrepresenting the behavior which you
might be able to apply now full
disclosure we're talking about a 1%
change in behavior 1% 1% probability
change in behavior overall I'm it's a
very large experiment so that a lot of
people are changed but but this is not
like predicting the gun eclipse this is
like being Las Vegas and being able to
do a little bit better on the dating
site OkCupid how tall do people say they
are and if you look at the the
distribution of how tall the men are
compared to how tall men are in the
population at large either people are
two inches taller that belonged to
OkCupid where everyone is just adding
two inches to their height how accurate
are these anything with the women
actually they're all they're taller no
in terms of reporting dating sites I'm
not the right one to ask about that I
don't know
I've been I've been out of the game for
a while but you but you because did you
have an early experience with this yes
but it wasn't online my wife and I did
meet through something but it wasn't an
online site but it was very helpful and
I'm eternally grateful
[Laughter]
yes we've gotten taller well today about
20% of people who end up getting married
say they met online for the first time
and that number has been pretty stable
for the last five years or so so I don't
know if it's gonna go any higher than
that but this is something where we are
a meeting is has has changed and the
interesting thing is that what that's
really substitutes we used to meet
people through family members more but
our friends are still in terminal and in
fact meeting people through friends is
actually increased at the same time as
meeting strangers online has increased
what about let's talk about tools for
the future we hear a lot about quantum
computing success how is this gonna
change the game of what we know and
analyze the data well so making
prediction so quantum computers are
these devices that my friends and I
build that are that store bits of
information on individual atoms and then
use quantum weirdness to to try to
calculate things that classical
computers can how much more how much
more powerful
could they be they could be so in fact
for exactly these kinds of big data
analysis kinds of methods they could be
very very powerful um give me a number
yeah so so actually you so so my friends
and I have also made some algorithms to
do common big data analysis things like
support vector machines and actually
these great topological methods we're
looking at we can morph different data
sets into each other and because these
methods are just based on ordinary kind
of linear algebra kinds of things and
quantum computers are exponentially
faster than that then then classical
computers for this so for instance this
let's take this this hypothetical data
set of all the genomes of all the human
beings on on earth there are 20 billion
bits larger than any data set that we
actually possess on computers right now
so to do a kind of clustering analysis
from this okay well you're gonna have to
like you know take around 10 to the 20
maybe 10 to the 40
operations on on a classical machine to
do very common analyses but on a colonic
computer you could analyze that data in
you know on the order of a few hundred
thousand times deaths and of course the
the bad news is we don't have quantum
computers yet that could do that but
quantum computers that might be able to
do that these kinds of simple operations
are around the corner and and basically
for people don't know the difference
between a quantum computer and a regular
computer that is that what what is a
qubit versus are the regular bit yeah so
the the quant the sent while okay so as
I used to say that my colleagues and I
we take you know the intrinsic ability
of quantum mechanics to process
information we exploit atoms and
molecules to make them compute but then
I realized that was terribly politically
incorrect so I stopped doing that in
fact I was stopped doing it when some
social anthropology have said to me Seth
you know rather than saying you exploit
atoms to make them compute why don't you
just say you empower it was a great
moment of my life I went from being an
exploiter of atoms to in a power of
atoms so so the kind of central
weirdness of quantum mechanics is that
something like an electron which can
store a bit like an electron over here
could be a zero or electron over here is
one and the distinction between zero and
one is a bit of information so in
quantum mechanics an electron can be
here and there at the same time and that
means that this quantum bit or qubit as
they call it actually when I was a kid a
qubit was this distance that qubit can
can in some funky quantum mechanical
sense that nobody really understands can
be zero and one simultaneously you know
if does who understands that I don't
understand that so they'll make use of
it you can still make use of it and what
the main use you can make is if you feed
that bit to a quantum computer then so
say zero says do this like add two plus
two one says do that add three plus one
then the cool quantum computer is now
doing this and that simultaneously
adding 2 + 2 + 3 +
at the same time and it doesn't have to
be just doing two things at once can be
for 816 a gajillion things that was a
gajillion is a large number is that fair
to say yeah so take the yes it for this
kind of analysis so the things that
involve things like you know finding
periodicity Xin in functions or or
identifying clusters in data so in
principle and as they say we don't have
the devices that can do this right now
in principle you could you could do this
you know billions of billions of times
faster or much more than a billion
billion times faster and how much more
accurate would that make the five-day
forecast if we could apply I'm not sure
that the limitation would the five-day
forecast is the computing power I mean
that's part of it but there's the issue
of measuring the state of the atmosphere
in the oceans that is you need to know
what the what the conditions are right
now to be able to predict what they're
going to be like tomorrow or a few days
from now and so we would need to have
sensors all over the place you know and
resolve to a much higher precision than
we have so I think even if we had much
better computers even exponentially
better as it may happen when quantum
computers come to exist that doesn't
mean we can predict the weather much
longer you know even it's really quite
nasty this is this issue of chaos that
is when we talk about the weather being
predictable out to you know on the order
of several days there's a sort of
fundamental limitation that has to do
with the dynamics of the atmosphere in
the ocean not with computing or
observation ability that is to say
there's a again actually the word
exponential will come in there's
something about the nature of chaotic
systems which in this case is the
exponential divergence between what
really happens in what we predict will
happen that that means that if you try
to predict say I mean roughly speaking
if I want to predict one unit of time
longer say one day longer I might have
to work 10 times as hard
in terms of you know 10 times the
resolution in my measurements or 10
times better computer and then if I want
to go 2 days longer I don't have to go
20 times better I have to now go 100
times better
that is it will grow by a factor in this
case I'm saying 10 it's not really ten
but I mean it grows by a constant factor
with each day that you want to improve
so I sort of think there's going to be a
really fundamental barrier to predicting
the weather more than you know a few
weeks I don't even think we'll ever be
able to predict a month I doubt we could
get to two weeks and it's because of the
weather it's not because of computing or
observation difficulties you can't be a
chaotic system you can't predict it much
longer than this time called its
predictability horizon or its I mean we
have jargon for what it's called but
could call it that the predictability
horizon and it's just kind of built-in
you can't do much about it so I I have
to say I'm a little bit skeptical about
a lot of the things we're talking about
here with regard to prediction of things
that unfold in time I think that's this
distinction I was trying to make earlier
we can predict as James genomics and
Andy have emphasized in a probabilistic
way if we're interested in correlations
what's the likelihood that you're going
to behave this way or by that thing but
it's still probabilistic and if you want
old-time prediction like we used to have
and you know predicting solar eclipses
or the planets that is a rare jewel in
in science it's we basically still can't
even do it today yeah give me that
old-time prediction they were we're
really weak at it I don't think we
should underestimate how tough
prediction is besides besides an eclipse
it's another old time well there are not
yet tides were good at now the tides
have the advantage I mean that's an
interesting example because the tides
are geophysical just like the weather
and yet we're really good at predicting
the tides and the advantage is that the
tides are basically periodic they repeat
the weather doesn't famously repeat and
that's fundamental to things that are
repetitious are go hand in hand with
being predictable well like eclipses
like Taylor's comes a time excuse me
time elements are difficult you know
what about the spread of diseases you
were talking about predicting that
that's I think that's that's time but
also there the issue is that we have a
network problem that that we don't
really know the actual social network of
who spreads diseases to who nevertheless
it's really interesting
I'm not talking about the online social
mean the real one where you're coughing
on someone and and it's it's hard
because sometimes it's a person on the
bus who is not part of your your life
they just happen to be on the bus so
there's a lot of randomness there and
yet it's amazing that like what James
was saying that that by looking at the
friend you know that is not just making
measurements of me but of my friends
because these tend to be friendly people
they are more likely to get coughed on
and so I mean maybe you should emphasize
a little what an interesting study you
did with the the Harvard undergraduates
although we don't have the full Network
yeah the part that we sample is on
average is going to be correlated with
the part that we don't sample under
certain circumstances and so if you if
you go out and you measure the fact that
this person has five friends you might
have missed the fact that they actually
10 but if you've asked the questions the
same with that person's everyone else
then on average he's still gonna be at
the top of the list compared to someone
there's four or three or two in reality
they have eight or six or four for
example but they're still gonna have
less so you still want to focus your
attention on these these people who have
more connectivity I'm in the network and
the interesting thing about the social
media data is that we are getting better
and better at predicting who the real
world friends are mmm so we published a
paper a couple of years ago and other
people have done this as well where with
84 percent accuracy we can predict who
amongst your friends on Facebook is your
best friend in real life if we were to
ask those two things separately and so
so we have some idea from this online
social network who you're actually
potentially coughing on and that may be
even more important than the guy in the
bus because there was a study I'm
protected by some other researchers that
looked at elementary school children and
got their social networks asked them who
their best friends were and they also
had the maps of the assigned seats and
classes and people were more likely to
get the flu from their best friends then
from the person who was sitting next to
them and so these real friend networks
although I agree that we're missing a
lot of information that would be
relevant for predicting the spread of
the disease there may be enough
information there in those as a proxy
for the whole network that they could be
really useful for getting advance
warning she was a real friend versus
Facebook friends right so face to face
face to face right you and I are friends
now
you're right oh yeah in that direction
you're up to three no feel like this Big
Bang Theory shelters I'm back to seven
so but the financial market is getting
back to this last question about quantum
computing and I want to say we have time
now for questions if you have questions
from the audience
if you want to come up and find the
microphones will be the last couple this
does does quantum computing have a
difference to predicting financial
markets it's there's that a time-varying
thing or financial markets is just hard
right and if I knew how to do it I'd be
rich right no I don't I don't know if it
does for that I mean quantum computers
are good for for specific kinds of
problems that um for instance that these
types of things that involve periodicity
z' there I mean there's now a quantum
computing company called D wave that
claims to be able to solve quite hard
problems and actually there there are
devices do seem to uh solve for hard
problems whether they're doing it better
than that classical computers or not I'm
not sure so but I don't think that I
don't see anytime soon that the that our
quantum computers are going to be doing
that much better in predicting financial
markets especially since we don't have
one since we don't have one right but of
course in predicting financial markets
not having a computer flipping a coin is
often you know a pretty good idea as
there was the famous dartboard dartboard
portfolio constructed at random by
throwing darts at the darts as long as
you have a large number of darts
actually works pretty well if you throw
one or two darts not so much but let's
keep in mind that there are people out
there who have predicted markets and
have gotten rich including James Simon's
so I think that prediction is possible
and we don't need the kind of prediction
of the solar eclipse type we can
actually do very well with short term
correlations if your objective is just
try to identify patterns and you can
trade on yeah we got two or three people
in the audience I'll start here gonna go
back there yes sir
the National Museum of mathematics and I
was curious about the fact that there
was no worldwide SARS epidemic is that
actually an instance for our ability to
predict the future predict how diseases
are transmitted really changed that
future because we're then able to do the
right things to to head off that from
happening if we hadn't done what we did
but it looks like one of the things that
was really effective there was getting
enough early warning that they could
shut down the airports to try to keep it
localized in China at the time I don't
know if you guys know any more about
this than that so so some of that is is
you know you start to realize how
important these these long ties are in a
network I mean those are the things that
always are are are capable of making
disease more infectious Steve has a
great paper published it was actually
the paper that inspired me in graduate
school with one of those collaborators
Duncan Watts where he shows that if you
take a regular ring like say we're all
holding hands it's gonna take a while
for something to go all around the ring
but if you just put a few of these long
distance ties as long as there's edges
in the network all of a sudden now it's
really easy to reach everyone all of a
sudden and so if you can really take out
those ties then then that's one way of
reducing the likely that the epidemic is
going to spread yes sir
science writer and I wrote a book called
techno creep what makes technology
creepy two of the things you mentioned
are in that book one of them is the
Progressive Insurance monitor and in
fact they don't use GPS they issue that
because they say they don't want to be
too creepy it's actually really usage
based insurance and we're target on that
example they actually brought it back
but they brought it back in a randomized
way so the pregnant girl still gets the
ad with the pregnancy stuff in it but
she also gets barbecues and power tools
my question is where do you think the
line is where we're gonna say it's too
creepy so in my experience but doing
research where I'm asking people for
their data I say give me your data and
they say no I say here's a little
picture of bouncing a monkey and then
everyone's saying yes yes yes yes yes so
with just a little bit of value just a
little bit of value to review preference
people are showing that they're willing
to share their data at a very large
scale it's not gonna be everyone but
it's certainly the vast majority of
people when you ask people about these
questions on surveys you tell them give
me your data
most people say no you say I'm gonna
give you a service in exchange for your
data you get 70 80 90 % depending on
what the service is that's why they're
always saying you can be entered in a
prize right yeah that's right maybe
perhaps you win yes yes this is about
weather and technological change
what is today the probability or
confidence level of predicting weather
two weeks forward and given the vast
exponential progress in technology what
was it forty years ago first of all I
predict it's gonna be hot in two weeks
from today
[Laughter]
summers coming on and you know but but
in terms of these I noticed that well
first of the United States is doing less
well than Europe because we actually
have fewer sensors and locally so but I
know more than five days doesn't really
seem to be possible
I mean nate silver's book in the signal
and the noise he has a chapter about
weather prediction and its improvement
and i don't know did you have a chance
to look at that yet or that might be a
place to look I don't know maybe some
people in the audience know if he
directly answers that question I don't
okay yes sir like to get a picture of
how you approach a single problem from
your different disciplines so could you
just go down the panel and everybody
pick one thing you would begin to ask or
think about if you were trying to figure
out if there was going to be a
fundamental change toward democracy in
China it's a going to be an evasive
answer but I feel like you're touching
on a point that we should have brought
up earlier since I'm plugging other
people's books the Black Swan seems it
should enter any discussion of
predictability and the limits of
predictability because what you're
talking about you know such a seismic
shift in that country going to democracy
would be a Black Swan event I mean it's
a really far-out thing that's hard to
predict it seems to me I mean maybe my
co-panelists will disagree that we would
the would the Egyptian revolution be the
same sort of thing that was been hard I
think so
in the timing of it I mean once it's so
so the characteristics of black swans
that seem to live mentions in his book
are that after the fact they look very
predictable and people make stories
about how we yeah of course we saw this
coming but meanwhile they didn't really
see it coming and there's no real theory
that will let them see it coming in that
something like it's a lesson we keep not
learning that we have this you Burress
that afterward we make stories about how
it's rational yet ahead of time we we
can't do it and the timing so I'm
willing to say now and you guys can
check me that within the next 20 years
China will democratize and the reason
why is because of the growth of the
middle class there and anytime that
you've seen growth of the middle class
to the levels are getting at now you've
seen Democrats transitions within the
next 20 years at in a number of East
Asian countries now maybe we shouldn't
be looking altogether anthropologist
would probably be all crazy now saying
oh you can't compare Korea to China for
this reason and that reason but you're
trying to generalize about those things
that conditions are right and this is
not just true because of economics of it
because of the social networks of it the
people in the middle class they tend to
have more friends they tend to be more
connected they're the people that you
would want to be watching to try to
figure out when one of these phase
transitions is going to occur and it
should seem perfect for financial
markets to want to know right absolutely
and I think that maybe the the point
that we should keep our eyes on is the
fact that prediction is different at
different horizons and so this idea of
predicting when a particular social
revolution will occur may be very
difficult but the idea of predicting
over a period of 10 or 20 years that it
will occur may be a very different
matter for example I don't know what the
weather's gonna be like three days from
now or eight days from now but I'm
pretty sure that six months from now
it's gonna be colder outside so I'm
pretty good maybe right but not very
useful what way well
so the question then is what are you
using the prediction for you know if
you're thinking about you know buying a
winter coat in six months it's actually
very useful if you're trying to figure
out whether to hold a party on a given
day maybe not so much so getting back to
the question that was asked about
democracy in China I would argue that
it's very difficult to predict that
event in any degree of precision for a
given year or two but over the course of
10 20 30 years I actually think it's
possible to predict that with a
reasonable degree of accuracy including
what's going on with the Arab Spring and
it's not so much just the middle class
although that's part of it I think that
James may be you know your your focus is
different from mine because you know I'm
focusing on the incentive structure the
middle class is not what gave rise to
democracy but rather it's the other way
around the democracy created a middle
class and what's driving it in my view
is the fact that capitalism in its
purest form communism in its purest form
both of those forms of government are
economically unsustainable they lead to
certain inefficiencies and breakdowns
that really can't be tolerated and so as
you get to an extreme ultimately you're
going to have a phase transition so I
think you could have seen and people did
see certain phase transitions coming but
you can't predict it to the year or the
day or the month unless you actually
have better and better data maybe with
if everybody we're forced to use
Facebook Twitter and all of these other
methods we could actually if the Chinese
government will force to use everybody
to use Facebook and Twitter and we'll be
monitoring the friends and the friends
and the friends of friends so closely
they'll know exactly whom to eliminate
when they start to try to write
[Laughter]
questions to communism or Castro in Cuba
whether you're welcome for predicting
that is it a much more difficult
question to predict and why would that
be it's not science I don't I don't know
what we're talking about I really feel
like we're just it this feels to me like
you know I mean it's very interesting to
talk about and maybe it's fine and we
could go on but but I think we're
kidding ourselves and the reason
why I do it because it's possible to
sprays this in terms of a testable
hypothesis which is exactly that like
what you do in in any other science so
hypothesis an increase in little class
makes democracy more likely an increase
in democracy makes the middle class grow
those are two testable hypotheses that's
fine at the level of you know the large
sample of looking at different countries
around the world but what if something
happens in North Korea that we're not
talking about because it's a black swan
or Pakistan decides to do some weird
thing right I mean these are this is how
history is gonna look when we're looking
back 50 or 100 or 500 years from now if
we're still here and you know they like
that crazy thing that started World War
one whatever it is that they're still
arguing about you know some people say
well oh of course you could see it
coming all right okay it's not going
hello I'm Kyle Clinton from Morton Beach
Florida early in the panel earlier in
the pack earlier in the panel you
mentioned that case involving target and
that pregnant daughter cookies elaborate
on mark king and a mathematics and
marketing but this time on a level of
demographics to certain areas at and the
plan at least demographics are going to
be less and less useful now that we have
the social context for a wide variety of
different prediction problems so you can
do a better job of predicting a person's
behavior by knowing their friends
behavior than by knowing their age or
their sex or any of the other
traditional demographic factors that we
typically use so Nielsen has been very
responsible for promoting this view of
oh well if you have a TV show it's going
to appeal to 25 to 32 year old women who
are stay-at-home moms right so and
political campaigns think this way as
well you know I have to think that way
anymore because we all live in our own
tribes that are unique that are defined
now by these social connections and if
you have access to that data you can get
specialized predictions for every single
person you don't need to know these more
generic things about them in order to be
able to make predictions they're just as
accurate as we have from from these
traditional categories
it's a useful thing to point out that
the reason target has all of that data
that they're able to make these
incredibly useful predictions is because
all of you use your target discount card
and every time you swipe that discount
card and you buy things they can
actually correlate that with your
demographics so I think ultimately we
give up data not because we want to not
because we feel that it's good but
because we actually get comments
compensated to do so okay we'll talk
more about this on Science Friday well I
want to thank all of you
[Applause]